in this video we're going to talk about
balance sheets and in particular balance
sheets for banks and a fractional
reserve lending system now it's not just
banks that have balance sheets all
corporations have a balance sheet you
can even have your own individual
balance sheet that is a snapshot of what
do you have a value and what do you owe
to other people now the things that you
have a value if we're talking about a
bank the things that the bank has of
value those are called assets and that
could be cash that the bank has in its
vaults it might be property that the
bank owns and the things that the bank
owes to other people are liabilities
liabilities and this might be money that
the bank owes to someone else some
future
lobbie obligation now there's this other
notion of equity and when we're talking
about a corporation like a bank equity
is what's left over if you take your
assets and you subtract your liabilities
equity is you could view it as the net
worth how much net value is owned by the
shareholders and to make this tangible
you can look at an analogy to your
everyday life if you're thinking about
your own personal balance sheet let's
say the only asset you owned was a car
that was worth $10,000 $10,000 car so
that is your asset and let's say that
you only have one liability you had to
borrow $8,000 in order to buy that
$10,000 car so this is something that
you owe to other folks so that is your
liability what would be your equity here
what would be your net worth well if you
own something worth $10,000 if all of
your assets are 10,000 but you owe 8,000
what you have left over that's going to
be $2,000 and so this would be your
equity in everyday language is often
times the net worth and so assets minus
liabilities is equal to equity or if you
add liabilities to both sides of that
you could say that assets are equal to
liabilities plus plus equity
and so when you see many balance sheets
it's typical to see it in two columns on
the left hand side you have assets and
on the right hand side you have
liabilities plus equity and these two
things should add up to the same amount
so whatever assets our liabilities plus
equity should add up to that same amount
so now let's use this framework to start
ourselves a bank and so let's say we
immediately go and buy a building and
some equipment worth a million dollars
just to even have a place to run the
bank and so we immediately have assets
of building building plus equipment plus
equipment of $1,000,000 now I just said
whatever our total assets are that would
be our liabilities plus our equity so in
this situation what are our liabilities
so far remember the balance sheet gives
us a snapshot at any moment in time well
so far I don't owe anything to anyone
I'll just assume that I had that million
dollars I didn't have to borrow from
anyone to to get that million so I have
zero dollars in liabilities and so what
would the equity be pause the video and
think about that well liabilities plus
equity needs to be 1 million dollars if
liabilities is zero then our equity is 1
million dollars so if I'm the owner of
the bank this tells me that the value of
what I own is 1 million dollars but as
we know banks don't exist just to be a
building they take deposits from people
and then they make loans to people so
let's say someone's walking down the
street and they see our bank and say hey
that looks like a good place to deposit
their money it looks like a safe place
maybe they'll get some interest on it
and so they come and they give a million
dollar cash deposit they have a suitcase
with a million dollars of cash in it so
how would that be reflected on this
balance sheet well it would actually get
categorized as reserves reserves you can
view as the Federal Reserve notes the
cash that it has on hand it could be
money that's in its vaults it could be
an account that it has with the central
bank although that gets a little bit
more sophisticated but you should just
you can visualize it as it's
one way to to simplify it and so in this
situation your reserves are now going to
be $1,000,000 where did that come from
it came from that suitcase of cash that
that person gave now what happens on the
right hand side of this balance sheet
they didn't just give us the money at
some future point in time they might
withdraw some or all of that money our
liabilities now so we now have a demand
deposit let me write it this way demand
deposit for 1 million dollars
and this is a good time to pause this
video and really understand this because
this is essential for understanding
banks is that yes we got that cash but
it's offset by a liability because at
some point in the future we have to give
that million dollars back to that person
who made that deposit and they can come
on demand now you might be saying
alright this is all nice but how am I as
a bank going to make money and the main
way that banks make money is by making
loans but how do they loan out the money
if all of this is on demand deposit well
in a fractional reserve system you don't
have to keep all of your demand deposits
on hand as reserves you can actually
lend out a good chunk of it and it's
dictated by what the required reserve
ratios are so let's say in the country
we're in or the jurisdiction we're in
the required reserve ratio so required
required reserve ratio is 10% of demand
deposits that means that we can look
whatever our demand deposits are we have
to keep 10% of that in reserves and then
the excess reserves we can loan out and
so I can now group my reserves and say
instead of saying a million dollars of
just total reserves I could sub
categorize it as required reserves
required reserves and excess reserves
now what do you think are going to be
the required and excess reserves in this
scenario pause this video and figure it
out
well required in excess are going to add
up to my total million dollars of
reserves the required reserves are
10% of the my demand deposits so I have
to keep 10% of this million dollars
which is $100,000 and then the rest is
excess reserves of $900,000 and so this
model is based on the idea that
statistically especially if these demand
deposits are coming from many different
people it's unlikely that more than 10%
will be will be withdrawn at any moment
in time and we can talk about runs on
banks where this tends to break down and
so banks will then lend out this other
90% of the demand deposits or up to 90%
of the demand deposits and they lend
them out to people they think are likely
to pay back the money with interest and
that interest is how banks make the
money and so this bank could say hey I
have nine hundred thousand of excess
reserves which okay which I can use to
make loans to other people and so let's
say a bunch of people come by and they
have some good ideas and we think that
they're going to pay us back so what we
do is we can take those excess reserves
up to nine hundred thousand dollars of
them and instead of having it as excess
reserves we can put them out as loans so
we can make loans of nine hundred
thousand dollars now one thing that
might be counterintuitive to some of you
is say wait I'm used to alone being
something like a liability here we just
said we owed people money and so that
was an obligation to other people why is
it an asset here well it depends if you
are the lender or you're the person
borrowing the money here as the bank
we're the lender the loan is an asset
because someone is going to pay us money
back in the future this has value if we
owed money to someone else well then
that would be a liability and so now
notice here the whole time that we were
doing this the assets were equal to the
liabilities plus equity assets right now
are two million dollars 1 million plus
one hundred thousand plus nine hundred
thousand and our liabilities plus equity
are two million dollars 1 million and
liabilities
1 million in equity